哈喽大家好,我是Hexen,欢迎来到我的频道
今天跟大家分享一个指标
是大家强力要求我分享的指标
叫OBV
它是一个可以观察到庄家的指标
庄家的一举一动都逃不过OBV这个指标
所以如果你想要跟着庄家的脚步
或者不想被庄家割韭菜的话
那么这个指标就可以帮助到你了
想知道这个指标是怎么用的话
就记得把影片看到最后,你得到最多的资讯
那么我们就直接开始吧
首先给大家明白
什么是OBV
它的名字叫
On Balance Volume
中文叫能量潮
它是由美国分析师
Joe Granville
在1963年所推出的一本书叫
New Key to Stock Market Profit
里所提出的
你看
它的名字有Volume这个字
所以它的计算公司
就是跟着Volume
就是跟着成交量来计算的
它把价钱的变动
以及成交量的增减关系
结合起来去推测市场的一个情绪
有没有听过
新手看价
老手看量
你想一下
当一只股票在一块钱的时候
有一万个人买
跟一只股票在一块钱的时候
有一百个人买
那么这两个之间有差别吗
当然有对不对
越多人在那个价位买
也代表着
他有更强的阻力或者支撑
或者是更多人的一个成本区
所以为什么说
OBV是一个可以观察到庄家的指标
是因为庄家要做价钱的时候
他就必须收票嘛
那么比如他买了300千张的票
那么他要开始推那个价钱的时候
他就必须卖掉手上的票嘛
那么量就会出来了
或者当价位在高点的时候
他的票是出完了
还是他才要开始出票
那么这些迹象就会被成交量所显示出来了
所以你看
庄家要做价的时候
他最喜欢的就是有量
因为有量就代表有人跟嘛
那么他要做事才比较容易
如果他收票收了很久
那么在他要做价钱的时候
没有人跟进去
那么它就完蛋了
对不对
所以根据OBV
你看量就可以看到庄家的动机了
那么接下来我们就说
OBV是怎么用吧
首先我们就去到Pick a Stock
然后按Technical Chart
然后大家就会来到了这个页面
我们怎么把OBV放出来呢
就是按Indicators
然后打OBV
就是这个On Balance Volume
然后至于设定的话
大家可以去到这里
按Setting
然后它有一条均线
是20
可以去到Style
然后通常我都会把Trend Background
关掉
所以这里就会有两条线
蓝色的这条就是OBV线
红色的这条就是它的均线
所以OBV是怎么看呢
大家主要就可以看蓝色这一条线
所以当蓝色这一条线
它越来越高
就代表它的量跟价钱的趋势
是越来越高越来越好
然后当OBV的线这样子跌下来的时候
就代表它的成交量
跟它价钱的变动
是没有趋势的
所以它就会跌下来
所以你看这一条蓝色线
你就可以把它想象成是一个来衡量成交量的指标
那么我们要怎么用它呢
第一个用法就是交叉
那么看到这条OBV线黄金交叉它的均线的话就是一个买入点所以我们来看我们把它放去最后一天在这一天的时候它是还没有交叉的嘛
那么我们再看这一天的时候
它就已经开始交叉了
如果我们再 double confirm
我们就从这一天开始
看到吗
它的趋势就更加高了
因为成交量代表有庄家进来了
所以我们就从这一天开始买起
那么我们几时卖呢
就是等这个OBB线穿破它的这个均线
那么像这一点的时候
就有已经一个穿破均线了嘛
这等一下我会跟大家讲解
然后主要的就是
大家就可以等到
它穿破了过后
然后它的这个
有一个比较大的距离
才算一个穿破的确认
所以我们就在这一点卖
那么如果跟着这个
交叉的交易法的话
就可以转这一大坡
像这里
它交叉了有一个距离
confirm
我们进
然后从这里
一个交叉处
这一天我们卖
OK
就是一个波段
所以当然它还是会有亏钱的时候
可是现在就要跟大家讲了
一个问题就是
用交叉的这个交易法的话
我就认为它不是特别可靠
你要怎么来定义
它一交叉你就买呢
大家看这一点
它是这样子
一交叉一点点
你就买进呢
还是要等到它
像这样子有一个比较大的空时间的时候
你才进呢
然后穿破的时候
是你要看到这样子
才一动到穿破你就卖呢
还是你要等到它比较大的空间呢
那么等到比较大的空间
大是几大才算大呢
对不对
我们需要有一个衡量的方式嘛
不能讲你看到大就是一个卖点
那么你的买卖点就不是特别精准了
所以你是说如果他一黄金交叉
你就买进的话
这里看到吗
有很多点买进买出买进买出
都是小小的这样子
或者像这个阶段
看到吗
他突破一点
这一点的时候你要卖吗
还是你要继续hold着呢
你要等他变大一点的时候你才卖吗
那么大是多少才算大呢
到这里算大
还是要等到这里才算大
虽然通过交叉的这种买卖法
不是那么可靠
但是他还是有他的厉害指出的
所以我们看这张图
我们希望我们买在哪里呢
我们当然是希望我们可以买在低点嘛
那么这个指标
可以让我们在比较靠近低点
捞到它的这个底部嘛
我们就看
它从这里一个黄金交叉了嘛
对不对
从这一天开始
我们在这里买进
它就可以在这一天的时候
就帮我们抓到了
我们这样子看回去的话
它是一个低点来的哦
对不对
然后它还有一个好处就是
它在这种一个跌生的状态之前
它都会给你一个卖出的讯号的
比如我们刚刚这里
这里是一个拉升了嘛
然后它卖下来的时候
你讲这个是跌破的话
你在这一天就可以卖掉了
如果你等到它的空间比较大一点
比如讲是这天
你在这一点卖
你也是可以避免了
你后面这个这样大坡的一个跌升
所以我也是认为是这个指标
非常强的一个功能吧
这里跌了那么深
但是它在跌了那么深之前
它在这一天就已经跌破了嘛
对不对
这一天的时候
如果你收盘才卖的话
你是卖在这一点
那么你也是可以省略掉了
那么大坡的一个跌升
对不对
然后OBV的第二种用法就是背离
也是我认为这个指标比较好用的一个用法吧
所以背离是什么呢
就是当指标创新低
但是价钱没有跟着它创新低那么价钱就会相反的走或者指数创新高但是价钱没有跟着它创新高所以价钱就会相反的走就会跌下来我们就可以看这个例子
比如这一天收盘在13块2
那么它的obv在这里
那么到这一天的时候
它的收盘价是比之前的高
对不对
但是它的obv是比之前的深
如果没有背离的状况
它的obv更加低
它收盘价应该更加低
可是他没有那么低
他反而是收到比之前的这个更加高
那么就是一个背离了
明白吗
他从这里跌到这里
这个应该也是从这里跌到这里
可是他从这里是上升到这里
那么这个是一个背离的状态
那么很有可能他接下来就会上涨了
我们可以再去看另外一个例子
所以我们看这里
这个就是一个背离
这个的低点是在这里
他的OBV在这里
但是他下一波的时候
他的收盘价是不是比之前的高
所以他的OBV应该从这里应该比之前的高
可是他比之前的低
所以就是一个背离
背离就有可能会有一个上涨了
所以高位背离我们就可以看这一个例子
所以你看这一点的时候
他的收盘价是在这里
那么到下一点的时候
他的OBV是不是比之前更加高
高那么一点点
那么他的收盘价应该也是跟他差不多同样高
或者高一点点
但是这一天的时候
他的收盘价只是在这里罢了
所以它就是一个背离的情况了
那么它可能就会有一个下跌了
我们再来看另外一个例子
我找了一个比较extreme的例子给大家看
我们看这一点
到这个高点的时候
它在这里
它的obv在这里
那么现在obv更高了这一天的时候
它的这一天是不是应该更加高在这边
但是它只收盘在这里
比之前的这个还低
所以它就发生了一个背离的状态
这个更加高
它的价钱应该更加高
但是它的价钱反而更加低
接下来很有可能就会有一个跌升的趋势了
那么我们知道它怎么用了
我们要怎么用在我们的现实交易里面呢
然后接下来我们就可以来go through一些股票
我们可以去按top 30
然后按exclude warrant
然后我们可以按看五天
这个就是一个五天的top gain
大家可以按右键
然后按technical chart
所以我们就可以大概的go through
像比如这里就可以看到一个了
大家看这一点
它的时候盘价在这里
对不对
然后接下来你看这一点的时候
这一天他收盘价是更高
他的obv应该更加高
可是他的obv没有太高
那么背离的状况接下来就很有可能是一个下降的趋势的
Enemy这次就没有太多可以看吧
因为他的成交量不是特别多
那么他的准确度就不是特别高了
所以Apple的obv都一直在他的均线上面的
所以如果我们在这个突破这里
这一天买进
这一天黄金交叉买进
现在还是有一个涨幅的
这个就是刚才我说的黄金交叉通病了
你看这样子的时候
它的平均线跟OBV都很靠近
那么你要怎么做决定
你很难对不对
然后我们可以看一下BORNIA这个比较大涨幅的话
如果用这个指标可以抓得到嘛
它的OBV跟它均线基本就是一条线来的因为它之前都没有什么量那么有量的时候那么它的Obv就会开始传上来的如果大家注意到的话可能就是这一天会买进在这一天
那么到现在
它传破的话
是在这一个期间
那么我们在这里卖
还是有一个涨幅的
然后我们再来看另外一只ql
所以突破的时候是在这一天
对不对
我们这里买进
那么如果根据这个指标
你买进了
它过后一个下跌
我们应该卖吗
它这个跌幅
他并没有跌破这个均线的
所以这个只是庄家洗盘的一个动作而已
就是说
庄家只是在把之前的这些人的票洗出去
他再用更低的成本再来推多一轮
而不是他真正的要卖掉他手上的票
如果他是要真正卖掉手上的票
这个OBV很有可能是会跌破这个均线的
可是看到吗
他这个跌幅是没有跌破均线的
所以他只是在做一个洗盘而已
所以再讲多一次
如果他真正是要丢票的话
这个OBV而先没有亮的时候肯定是会跌破这个均线的
然后我们再来看最后一支吧
它第一次突破是在这一天嘛
对不对
我们在这里买进
那么如果根据OBV这个方法
它都还没有跌破这条均线
那么你就不必卖了
所以跟刚才讲的一样
如果你买了过后下来这个跌升
可是它并没有跌破这个均线
代表它只是一个短暂的洗盘而已
你在这一天买
它只是想把之前这里的人洗掉
那么它再重新来一次
像这里你应该要卖吗
你应该要恐慌吗
他并还没有跌破这条均线
所以他做这一波
也只是想要把这里前面的人
全部洗掉而已
所以如果你有根据OBB这个方法
你就不会被他洗掉了
然后接下来很有可能
又是在一个拉伸了
我们就来看一下另外一间公司
你看在一个大跌之前
他一定会在之前就警告你先聊的
他在这里就已经开始跌破
他的均线了嘛
对不对
如果你在这里不卖
他这个已经跌得那么深
你在这里也应该卖了
如果它上涨你再买回
那么这里的时候
它又叫你在卖
那么你在这里卖了过后
它接下来就没有再突破了嘛
也没有买进的机会了
那么接下来就是一个大跌了
所以这个就是
当他们真正要丢票的时候
之前就已经会有给你一个警告了
最后我们来做一个总结
我认为OBB不是一个买进
或者卖出的讯号
它是一个帮你预测的讯号而已
虽然这个指标也能把它用成
一个买进或者卖出的讯号
但是它并不是一个特别靠谱的讯号
个人认为这个指标最强的特点就是
当股价在暴跌之前
它一定会给出你一个讯号
所以当你买了一只股票
你有赚钱了
然后你又觉得那个价位现在好像是在高点
然后你又没有一个策略来决定你的卖点的话
你就可以参考这个指标了
如果你想要老底
就是你想要买在最靠近底部的话
它的反应就没有别的指标块了
还是我在课程跟大家介绍的老底指标
是更加灵敏
更加好用的
好吧
如果今天大家有学到
OPB这个词标的话
就记得订阅和点赞
那么才不会错过
后面更加好的内容
那么今天我们就说到这
我们下次再见
拜拜